i'm clark askins this is todd valena
we're sres at linkedin uh we run kafka
zookeeper and
samhsa for linkedin um and so why are
you guys here
you wanna learn more about kafka
obviously right um
and or maybe you already use kafka i
think a lot of you do
and you wanna see how we run it we i
think we have one of the largest
installations
in the world for kafka and we'll show
you guys some tricks
um like i said this is who we are
um so sre do you guys know what that
term means
site reliability engineer so yeah we're
uh
basically the administrators yeah yeah
it's right there i was checking to see
how many years you had
so um we're the administrators for the
architects we developed cool tools
um our goal is to keep the site running
all the time
so here's todd with the overview of
kafka all right
so some of you know what coffee is
already
gonna assume that not everyone does
though so yeah this isn't
what we're talking about today although
this is still our logo
officially well now we've kind of
officially this is the new logo
if you haven't seen it this is the kafka
logo now it's no longer
kafka it's like chemistry
anyways so we're not talking about that
guy today
so what makes up kaufman coff is a
publish subscribe messaging system what
does that mean
so in the cockpit space we have brokers
that's what we call a server
it talks to zookeeper because we store
all of our metadata in zookeeper
information about topics and brokers and
consumers and everything else
for now we have producers
and we have consumers so all of our data
is broken down
into topics which are broken down into
partitions so here we have one topic
named a
with one partition zero
we don't like just one partition though
one partition doesn't help us very much
and we'll see why in a sec so now we
have two partitions and so our producer
is sending messages
into these partitions so he sends a
message
message gets stored in the kafka broker
the consumer eventually reads it out
the consumer talks to both partitions in
this case because we only have one
consumer
if we had two consumers one of them
could talk to each of the partitions
so but this doesn't work for us because
we also want some reliability when we
want some redundancy in our system so
now we have two brokers and we've split
our partitions out
what this gives us is when when we have
our data our partition so here we have
a partition one and we have partition
zero over here
but we've also replicated the data so
that now whenever we write data into
partition zero it gets copied over to
the other broker
vice versa this way when one of our
brokers dies
the other broker can instantly take over
and continue serving messages the
producers and the consumers rebalance
as long as they're implemented correctly
and
life goes on when our broker comes back
up it doesn't do
anything all it does is start receiving
the data again so it doesn't take over
again it's not a situation where it
suddenly comes back up and says okay i'm
the master again
start sending messages to me you have to
actually do something or you have to
fail another part of the cluster for
that to happen again
but this works out really well because
now it means we have redundancy of our
data
we have reliability in our system
because we can lose a component and
still keep on with life
so what is our kafka cluster the first
thing is it's disk based this is as
opposed to
a number of other messaging systems
where messages are stored in memory
they're not retained for any period of
time
kafka is a log oriented system it's
referred to by many people as a
distributed commit law
everything gets spooled out to disk you
can have retention
for any period of time that you want so
we have durability as you saw we had
multiple partitions we had multiple
copies of those partitions
so whenever we write our data out we
know it gets stored in multiple places
we don't have to worry about
losing a broker and losing our data it's
also scalable
if we have more traffic into a topic we
just add more partitions
if we start maxing out a one broker with
network or anything else disgaea for
example
we just spread it out move our
partitions
we move our partitions out to more
brokers and we can handle as much load
as we need
it's low latency we're talking on the
order in general
under a second propagation from
producers to consumers
usually less when you start adding
multiple clusters that's where you
introduce your latency so usually you're
talking about milliseconds 10
milliseconds 12 milliseconds
messages move through the system very
quickly
and you have finite retention so you can
configure your retention right now in
three ways you can retain messages based
on time
so for example most of our clusters we
retain data for a week
you can retain messages based on size so
you can say i only want to retain a
gigabyte of traffic
or gigabyte at any given time in this
topic
you can also retain in key based
retention what that is
is you have a topic and you write in a
key
and every time you write a new message
with that key it replaces the old
message and there's a process that goes
through and cleans things up and this is
fairly new for kafka
and i think it seems to be working
pretty well in a couple of places we've
got it
got it going on at linkedin so far
the last thing is it's not item potent
if a producer produces the same message
into the system twice
that message gets stored in the system
twice it gets consumed out of the system
twice
this says yet because that's actually a
project that we're handing
off to an intern hopefully this summer
to work on
adding item potent messages of course
you can kind of do item potent messages
with the key based retention already
so it's kind of there it's kind of not
so how do we use kafka at linkedin we
have multiple data centers and multiple
clusters in each data center we break
things out by the type of data that
we're putting in
and we do a lot of mirroring data
between the clusters so that we can
propagate data from one data center down
to another
so we have it produced in the production
data centers for example and we
propagate it back to our corporate
environments where we may consume it for
metrics or something else we have
multiple different types of data going
through our system as well
we have metrics as i mentioned which is
everything from
operating system statistics like cpu
disk usage
memory usage application statistics
call times for any particular part of
our applications
we have tracking data which is
everything the users do on the front end
of the site every single action that's
taken by one of our servers is pumped
into the tracking cluster
propagated back to hadoop for processing
for reporting and everything else
and then we have queuing between
applications we use this for sending
emails we use this for
you know just inter inter uh application
discussions when you want to just
get something off or pass it on to
another part of your application
we're discussing with a few people that
we're coming up with new uses every day
for kafka now one of our
internal customers wants to use the
queuing cluster to replace bittorrent
and send out multi-gigabyte files
through kafka
and we've talked about it it sounds like
a really neat idea
and they have a good idea of how they
want to do it we'll just see how well
that execution goes
uh they have the reason they want to do
it is because they've had some problems
with bittorrent
and they think that this will be a
better solution for them so
you you look you look questioning to
that incredulous
yes so did we but uh it
seems like it could work pretty well for
them for the the particular use case
that they're doing
so as i said the tracking data what we
do is kafka spends a lot of time
transporting data to hadoop it gets
processed and then gets
sent back out to the production system
so for example users take an
action they look at something it gets
passed back to hadoop
it gets processed by the the um
well just lost the word the uh
oh man anyways it gets processed it gets
sent back out so now the search updates
are search results are updated the
things like people you may know and jobs
you may be interested in
are updated on the front end as that
data propagates back out
the real difference at how we're running
kafka at linkedin is that we're running
it as a service it is a platform for the
rest of the company to use
we don't really know anything about the
data that's coming in or the data that's
going out
as the sres we're just responsible for
keeping the system up and running all
the time
making sure that it's available for
everyone else and when they come to us
and say
we'd like a topic with 720 partitions
we say wait a sec why do you want 720
partitions
and we make them explain it to us and
then we say oh okay we'll set that up
for you
that was the discussion we had earlier
today actually
so why are we standing up here talking
to you about it and i'm going to warn
you that
everything on this slide is now a month
old so all the numbers are bigger
we have over 300 kafka brokers and i
think the number's over 400
now we've we've been doing a lot of
expansion in the last month or so
we have over 18 000 topics in our system
and we have over 140 000 partitions
not counting replication of partitions
so
double that number we're doing 220
billion messages per day through
the kafka brokers in our system and it's
about 40 terabytes of data coming
in on the outbound side we're doing 160
terabytes and this is why we really love
kafka as a log based retention system
because
we're consuming out more data than we're
putting in all the time
one of our uh favorite consumers
actually pumped reads out the data 60
times
for every every message that's produced
in they read out 60 times
uh this is not necessarily the best use
case
we're having discussions with them about
it but uh it's what they're doing
and it's working for now at peak
we're doing three and a quarter million
messages per second
it's about five and a half gigabyte giga
bits per second
inbound to all the clusters and 18
gigabits outbound so again
always we're reading in a little bit
we're writing out a lot to our consumers
so i'm going to hand it back over to
clark at this point to talk about some
of the other interesting things that
we've been doing here
all right so we've had lots of
challenges uh running this at scale
so um kafka is still really young we
one of the great things that we have the
opportunity to do is we sit with the
developers every day so five of i think
eight committers on the kafka project we
sit with every day
and so we're able to uh push them and
say hey we need this feature
um and you know it takes time for
developers to
get things rolled out so we have to do
some tricky things
to make things uh not fall over before
that new feature comes out
so one of the biggest problems we have
is hyper growth so
everybody all of a sudden wants more
data there's always more data
and it's always useful data so we never
delete data there's always just
ever growing amount of data um so
one of the uh cool things that came out
with
kafka 081 is uh
well so whenever you add a broker with
kafka before oa1
whenever you added it wouldn't actually
do anything you'd add in the new broker
and it would just sit there and do
nothing until a new partition
or a new topic was created but with 081
now what we're able to do is move
partitions on the fly
to that new broker and so what we've
been able to do is write a script that
will
take and look at the data size on disk
and make sure
that's even across every single broker
in the cluster so these are all moving
you know
while the cluster is uh we've written
that script
um another interesting use case we have
is logging in metrics
so at linkedin the logging and metrics
go to the same kafka cluster
so why is this an issue well if a
developer releases new code
that doesn't work quite right they start
generating tons and tons of log messages
and it'll eventually kill the cluster
so one of the other cool things with the
partition reassignment tool
that we were able to do is we were able
to essentially create a cluster within a
cluster
so what this is is uh what we call qos
so we're able to move all of partition
or all of topic a
onto a specific set of brokers and so
what we did is we moved all of our
metrics topics
onto a specific set of brokers that was
not the logging
set of brokers so that whenever these
things happened
we didn't lose visibility into what's
going on across the site
um let's see so we also had deployment
nightmares so with kafka as todd
mentioned you know there's
two replicas generally of every single
topic well if you have more than
two brokers down at any given time
within a cluster
you start losing data those partitions
are offline and so
uh we were really scared to start doing
parallel deployments
or you couldn't do parallel appointments
and so what we were able to do is
influence
the developers to ensure that only one
broker was ever offline at a time
so if we issued a parallel stop to the
entire coffee cluster
only one of the brokers would shut down
because before they shut down they check
the health
of everyone else in the cluster to
ensure that they're up they're
functioning
and then one of them would be elected to
shut down
um so we did spend a lot of time
babysitting sequential deployments until
we got this new feature added
um yeah we cried about it a lot
um now deployments are a lot easier um
make sure that the cluster's in the same
state before anything shuts down
unless you kill mine it then yeah you
can't mind it
so um let's see let me talk about that
so zookeeper so the way that the
consumers work
is every consumer is part of a consumer
group and what that allows you to do is
parallelize your data consumption
so we have multiple partitions across
all the brokers and you could
theoretically run
the same number of consumers as you have
partitions and you
every consumer in that group or the
entire group would only read
each message once all of that offset
information about where each consumer is
is stored in zookeeper
and as todd mentioned we have 18 000
partitions at linkedin
topics topics 18 000 topics 140
000 partitions um and so each one of
those has multiple consumers
they're all updating their offset data
constantly
and so what this did is it overwhelmed
our security cluster
it couldn't handle the number of writes
that we were uh pushing into it
so what we were able to do is we put
zookeeper on ssds
problem solved you know there's lots of
conflicting information on the internet
about whether or not this is a good idea
or not
we did it um our average latency went to
zero milliseconds
we were quite scared when we saw that
zookeeper
zookeeper only has millisecond uh
accuracy
for the latency measurement so
everything just went to zero and we're
like is this thing still working what's
going on
and so sure enough it was actually it
was working everything was great
um and yeah it's i think it's still
average of zero yeah
so um how many do you never zero
how many zookeeper clusters do we have
so
each cluster that runs kafka in each one
of our data centers has uh there's one
cluster
that runs all of the kafka clusters one
zookeeper cluster
running all of the questions how many
replicas uh there's five nodes in the
zebra cluster
all right so now monitoring all right
so uh kafka is used to monitor
every single thing at linkedin like i
mentioned all of the metrics go through
kafka
the um back end systems that do all the
graphing and all the alerting read that
data out of kafka in our corporate
environment
so every single application every single
server has multiple touches to kafka in
our environment
so this makes it very sensitive as a
an internal data product so you know
almost every single day someone comes
crying to us
kafka's broken so
i i know some of you have daughters i
know
some of you know that this is pinkie pie
because i have two daughters
and that's how i know it and i know that
you know that pinkie pie is always happy
our kafka our kafka consumers are always
happy because we transport all their
data around for free they don't have to
do any of that work
so why is she so cranky all of a sudden
because kafka's broken
everything's kafka's fault first so
everything touches kafka
so whenever anything breaks whenever
there's any exception in the log files
if it even remotely mentions kafka
all of a sudden it's our fault and we
have to get involved and figure out
what's going on
and this is why we are on call and this
is why our developers are on call
because
either we're going to look at it and
determine that there's a problem with
the kafka servers
or the developers are going to look at
the application and determine why that
particular application
isn't using kafka properly
but really what it comes down to is
almost always the consumer problems are
with lag
and rebounds so what's lack
lag is the difference between where the
kafka broker
is as far as messages which we call the
tail
the end of the log and where the
consumer is with
reading messages which is generally
somewhere further back than the tail so
that difference between where the
consumer is and where the broker is
is our lag so
why is why is lag a problem for us
it's not really it's a consumer problem
it's their problem their application is
slow
they're doing too much garbage
collection and they're
they're falling behind or they're losing
their connection to zookeeper or kafka
or something else
they've implemented their consumer
incorrectly uh they brought up six
servers in parallel and they suffered
five sequential rebalances of their
consumers as each one came up it
caused the the consumer group to
rebalance once again and then they hit
their limit of five rebalances
and their application panicked on the
sixth time and said
oh i can't start up and it fell over and
died
these all come back to consumer issues
so you know
we have to educate our users as to
how to use kafka properly so they just
want to write their data in
and get their data out but we have to
help them use it properly we have to
teach them what to monitor about their
application and what to look for in the
logs
and this is why our developers spend a
good bit of time looking at other
people's log files
and determining what a particular error
message means
now errors with the application
generally come down to application
problems as i mentioned
gc long processing times or
sometimes it's a kafka client problem
there are bugs in the kafka compliant we
will we will freely admit that
and then we hand it off to the
developers and let them figure out what
the bugs are and fix them
so sometimes it is in fact something of
a kafka problem and every once in a
while
it is an actual kafka problem that we
have to fix the broker because the the
broker fell over and died or the cluster
is being slow
so if everyone's calling us constantly
how do we end up sleeping at night
because we're the ones who are on call
we're the ones who have to respond to
all of these things
as i said the first thing we do is
educate our users we teach them what lag
is
how to monitor it and how to resolve it
when it's an issue what to go looking
for
mostly we teach them why lag is their
fault and not ours
we're also spending a lot of time
monitoring our system so we want to make
sure everything's healthy because the
first thing that we need to do
whenever somebody comes to us with a
problem is go in and look at the kafka
ecosystem and say yes
our system is healthy everything is
working properly so let's go look at
your application and see what might be
going on on that side of things
this means we're monitoring the kafka
brokers we're monitoring zookeeper
constantly
we're monitoring our mirror makers which
if you don't know what mirror maker is
i'll get into it in just a minute
we also have an audit infrastructure
which i'll also cover along with the the
mirror makers that helps us assure all
our data is getting where it's supposed
to be
and then we have rest interfaces to
kafka as well for those users who either
can't or don't want to use the java
client for one reason or another
the other thing that we're looking at in
addition to the metrics at any given
time is we're looking at our week over
week metrics so we compare
everything we're doing this week to what
we did last week so that we can watch
organic growth over time and know when
we need to expand our clusters
we can also know that if we had a spike
in traffic
last week at 10 o'clock on monday
and we had a spike this week at 10
o'clock on monday and maybe three weeks
ago we had a spike at 10 o'clock on
monday
that might be normal and so we don't
really need to be concerned about that
particular alert if that's a normal
normal state of being for us so when it
comes to the kafka brokers what are we
looking at the one thing that you need
to monitor if you're monitoring nothing
else about kafka is
under replicated partitions this is when
you have
a broker down or otherwise you have two
replicas and one of those replicas is
not available for some reason
this means you're running your your
cluster in a degraded state
you can see a couple different types of
things with under-replicated partitions
you might just see the numbers spike up
and then drop back down immediately
that generally means you have a load
problem you you got a spike of data into
the cluster you maxed out a network
interface
and so you'll see partitions go under
replicated and then they'll go back
but if you see a bunch of clusters a
bunch of brokers in the cluster that all
have a high under-replicated account
then you probably just lost a broker and
you need to look into why you lost one
of your servers and get it back
up as long as you have under-replicated
partitions so we
we run with replication factor two that
means we always have one copy of every
partition
one extra copy of every partition so if
we see under replicated partitions
that means we can only lose we can't
lose any more servers than that we can
lose one server
once we lose one server we're degraded
if we lose a second server for some
reason then we have offline partitions
and we're losing data out of our systems
data can't get written in data can't get
read out
so we're monitoring offline partitions
but
if that number's ever anything other
than zero we have a serious problem we
want to catch it at the under-replicated
state not at the offline state
we're also looking at the number of
partitions that each broker has as clark
mentioned we wrote a script to actually
level
the number of partitions on each broker
so it's not quite as simple as just the
count
we want an equal number of partitions
but really what we want is an equal
amount of data across partitions so the
data size on disk is actually more
interesting than the broker count
is so we're looking at that as well
we're also looking at the number of
leaders that each broker has this is
so for as i mentioned top you have
replicas
if you're not familiar with kafka then
you might be a little confused when we
talk about leaders because
only one broker is ever the leader for a
given partition so you may have two
replicas
but only one broker is actually talking
to the consumers and producers you
can't read data out of the other replica
you can't write data into the other
replicator
replica all you can do is copy data over
to it in case there's a failure
so we want to know that our leader count
is balanced across all the brokers
because that means each of our brokers
is getting about the same amount of load
and there is an automated feature to
balance
the to automatically rebalance the
leaders in the partition whenever they
go out of whack
doesn't really work that well at this
point so
this is a task that we have to do
manually if things get out of whack
and then we look at our network
utilization as i said if we
max out a network interface you start to
see under replicated partitions
so this is a situation we want to avoid
in general
we don't run anything else on the kafka
brokers so all of the traffic through
the network interface is due to kafka
and if we're maxing things out
and we're doing it on a regular basis
then we need to add more brokers to the
cluster
to add more capacity across the board
monitoring zookeeper this is the other
thing that we have to look at both the
brokers and the consumers for now
talk to zookeeper so in general
zookeeper is a fairly simple thing
to to operate we want to know that the
ensemble is available
just anyone who doesn't work with
zookeeper and ensemble is what you call
a cluster in zookeeper
somebody didn't like the word cluster so
it's an ensemble
so you want to make sure that you're on
your ensemble is available so if we're
running
five zookeeper nodes we need to have at
least three of them we need to have a
quorum of at least three zookeeper
servers
so we lose one we can only lose one more
before the
the zookeeper cluster's in danger of
being unusable
and since we're talking to zookeeper and
everything's talking to us that's not a
good situation to be in
looking at the latency it's tough
it's very hard now monitoring a stream
of zeros
but we do it it should always be zero
our outstanding counts as well because
zookeeper
processes requests serially one request
comes in it gets handled
it gets sent sent out the next request
gets processed
if we have outstanding requests it means
things are backing up for some reason
and we need to look into why things are
backing up
there's some processing problem brings
us to mirror maker
and audit so
here we have a simplified view of our
kafka cluster we have a producer who's
writing messages into our cluster
what mirror maker does for us is it
allows us to replicate data from one
cluster to another cluster
and we use this for propagating data
between our data centers we use it for
propagating data back to our corporate
environment where we do processing
or we look at the metrics or whatever
else we're doing
we spend a lot of time copying data
around our system to the point that we
probably have more traffic in mirror
makers than we do in
actual applications producing data into
the system
so what do we monitor with mirror maker
and we monitor the lag
and i know i said that lag's a consumer
problem but in the case of mirror maker
it is consuming the data out of one
cluster and producing it into another so
as a good kafka user we monitor our lag
and we keep an eye on what's falling
behind because if this lag on this
starts to increase it means the data's
not getting to this cluster
which means our monitoring applications
aren't going to work for some reason or
another and
hadoop processing is going to stop and
our
executives are not going to get their
reports and when executives don't get
their reports they get cranky and when
executives
cranky we get emails and we get phone
calls and it's
not a happy situation for anyone
involved
we also monitor drop messages our goal
is zero drop messages
and that's what our alerts are all set
at if anything goes over zero
we're losing data out of our system as
we transport it back to hadoop back to
our metric system
now it may not be as important on the
metrics side because we can lose a
message or two and we still have an
overall view of the system
but when we lose tracking data out of
the system we're losing money
uh tracking is what our users are doing
it's ad impressions it's
you know emails into the system it's
emails everything goes through the
tracking cluster
so that's where we start losing money
and we have to keep an eye on it
which is why we also have an audit
system structured around
around kafka the audit is a piece that
is custom to linkedin it's not part of
the open source stack at this point
although there is talk about open
sourcing it
as it as we can what the audit consumer
does
is every producer in addition to the
messages that it's writing into the
system
is also producing messages into a
special topic about how many messages it
produced
so over a 10-minute window it will send
a message into this topic that says i
sent 100 messages into topic x over the
last 10 minutes
so all of that data ends up in our kafka
cluster and it also gets mirrored
as part of our mirror maker strategy and
then we have this audit consumer
that reads from every cluster and what
it does is it consumes
every single message out of the kafka
cluster
and it calculates counts on how many
messages it sees in each
topic and it writes data back into the
same special topic
that says over this 10 minute period i
saw 100 messages in topic
x at this cluster and the audit consumer
at the next cluster down does the same
thing
it writes it reads all the data out of
that cluster and it writes counts back
in and all of this data gets propagated
through the system
so uh what are we monitoring with our
audit consumers
so i haven't hit the interesting part of
audit yet but
with our audit consumers we monitor lag
they're consumers we have to make sure
they're up to date because
if they fall behind then all of our
tracking information falls behind as
well
we don't know how many messages got
produced
we're also doing a completeness check on
the data this is where the last part of
the audit system comes in
so at the lowest tier of kafka we have
an audit ui
it reads data out of all of the clusters
so it reads data out of this cluster it
also reads data out of every other
cluster
at kafka the only topic it reads is that
special tracking
that monitoring topic so it's reading
all of the counts it's reading
everything the producer said it wrote in
everything the audit consumer said it
saw and it does
it puts all that data together and
generates us nice pretty graphs
that show for each tier how many
messages there were in each topic
over any given period of time it shows
us the percentages of how much
data got through so it's looking for the
producer said it got 100 messages
the audit consumer here said it got 100
messages the audit consumer here said it
got 99 messages
oh [ __ ] we have a problem now so now we
have to go back and find out what
happened to that last message
and if that number ever drops below 100
we get emails we get emails the
developers get emails
the hadoop etl team gets emails because
that stops the hadoop pipeline from
working properly
but really what we end up looking at is
nice pretty graphs that show our topics
and the period of time and we can see
here that one of our clusters
is dropping off as far as event counts
in this particular case we have an audit
consumer in that cluster that's falling
behind because
it's under capacity and so we had to
resolve that situation
we also get nice information about how
long it takes to load our data through
the system
so all of our all of our clusters are
sitting here down at the bottom right
around
11 minutes 10 11 minutes because there's
a 10 minute granularity in the system
and then this one cluster shot up to 233
minutes at one point because it was
getting its data very slowly
but this helps us assure that all of the
data gets through our system
and it helps us assure to everyone else
that yes you're seeing every single
message that was produced into the
system
and you're getting all the things that
you want to see
so now that i'm done talking about
monitoring
we can monitor our system so we know
that it's healthy so how do we make sure
that it's running at peak performance
kafka is a pretty stable application as
far as things go and it's fairly good at
doing what it does it processes
the messages through the system very
quickly and there's very little tuning
that you have to do past the defaults
with kafka until you start getting into
some weird situations and we're starting
to look at some
you know tuning i o threads and other
things but once you get it running
it just tends to work properly so really
we're talking about hardware and os
tuning a lot of the time
and we're talking about java tuning and
that's
generally what it comes down to so with
the hardware in the operating system
we start with our kernel tuning there's
not too much to do
the biggest thing is you don't want to
swap you never want to swap
swapping is bad swapping will instantly
slow down kafka to a crawl then your
data doesn't get through the system
nobody's happy
now there's an interesting note to this
so we set swappiness equal to zero
on all of our servers however
we just found this out recently that in
red hat six four they changed the
meaning of swappiness equals zero
swapping this equals zero used to be a
request to cut to the kernel
that says please don't swap just don't
do it if you can avoid it but it would
still swap
if it had to if you started to run out
of memory it would swap the disk
no longer in 6.4
swappiness equals zero is a demand
yes exactly because what happens is if
you
killer if you run out of memory it will
not swap
it will instead om your processes this
is not a happy situation for kafka or
really any database or anything else
that you're
trying to get data through so we're now
switching all of our servers over
to swappiness equals one which basically
it's a scale of zero to a hundred
as far as how likely it is to swap so
it's it'll be one percent likely to swap
instead of zero percent likely to swap
but the difference is is that at equals
one it's still a request it's not a
demand
so that is an interesting thing to know
one of the other things we do is we
allow more dirty pages in memory
uh we've got lots of memory on our
servers we are using most of it in page
cache
so we just we let it we let the dirty
pages build up
but we allow less dirty cache in the
system because we really want that cache
to be available all the time for us to
use we're doing a lot of disk i o
we're doing a lot of network i o so
disk io that's the other big thing that
we have to worry about we're flushing
everything to disk constantly
so the biggest thing that you can do for
your desk is more spindles
we actually run all of our kafka brokers
with a raid 10
of 14 disks so we get as much
performance out of those disks as
possible while still having a little bit
of redundancy built into them
and we allow a longer commit interval on
that mount point
so whereas the normal cuff whereas the
normal kernel commit interval
for an ext3 mount point is 30 seconds i
believe between
flushes we actually set it to 120
seconds
the reason that we do this is because we
can tolerate
losing two minutes worth of data if the
system crashes because we know it got
written to another one of the kafka
brewers
so when that server comes back up after
a crash it's going to have to recover
all its log files anyways
so we'd rather squeeze out the extra
performance by extending those commit
intervals a little bit more
are you using bbu or flash cache for
your rate we
are using yes there is there is cash on
the raid and their battery backed up
so that we get that last commit but the
disc
won't flush from the kernel to the raid
for that last bit
so if it gets to the raid card it's fine
but if it doesn't get from the os to the
to the raid controller then you're going
to lose that bit there so there's still
going to be some in memory that doesn't
actually
get flushed to the raid controller
so the other side of tuning kafka tuning
the system is tuning the jvm
and really when we're talking about
tuning the jvm we're talking about
garbage collection
now eyes glaze over when we start
talking about tuning garbage collection
because to most people this is a dark
art
it requires sacrificing small animals
and arcane rituals
and knowing all the little things to
poke and spending months and
months tweaking parameter after
parameter until you find
just the right combination of flags that
gives you the optimal performance
and then your workload changes and you
have to do it all over again
we skipped all of this so
recently we moved to uh java 7
update 51 and life has been wonderful
for us we
stopped doing we stopped spending any
time whatsoever on tuning because what
we got was the garbage first collector
for those who aren't familiar with this
the garbage first collector is designed
to take
all of the joy out of tuning the garbage
collection
garbage first tells you look just tell
me how much memory i have to work with
tell me how long you want your gc pauses
to be and leave me alone
don't set sizes for anything don't try
to tweak anything else just let me
figure it out
and it's actually pretty good at it
so you set the heap size we actually set
our heap size to four gigs now
you specify a gc pause time this is the
target time you want
it's not a guarantee you're asking the
jvm to please try and hit this target
uh it should be reasonable otherwise
you're going to spend all your time in
gc
uh we specify 20 milliseconds for ours
and we're hitting that pretty
consistently within a millisecond or two
and you don't set anything else so used
to be you would set the new generation
size
if you fix the new generation size in g1
you override the pause time
target so it doesn't really help you
very much
so what did we see when we switched to
uh g1 collector and and i'll tell you
that
we did this over a week when our boss
was in hawaii
on vacation uh and he was reading emails
wondering if we knew what the hell we
were doing as we were
rolling this out across the board and it
all turned out for the best the biggest
problem we we thought we were going to
have was moving to java 7
and we actually did not have any
problems with kafka under java 7.
so what did we get we spend less than 15
milliseconds per second in
gc and i said our our pause time target
is 20 milliseconds so we're doing less
than one
uh young gc per second now
more importantly we're seeing steady
20 to 22 millisecond gc intervals all
the time so we can count
on what our gcs are going to be across
the board and we know it's not going to
slow down our application significantly
the most important thing we don't see
any more full gc cycles
at all the only time we see a full gc on
a kafka broker is if someone
really drives load into the system and
it overloads
usually overloads the network interface
then we will see one
gc one full gc on a broker or two
within the cluster and then it goes back
to normal yes uh
a quick topical question in this but
not necessarily to kafka but how do you
are you able to actually monitor
how much of that heat is being consumed
so that you have some sort of advanced
warning that you're
about to uh exceed your your request or
is the only way that you know that you
exceeded it the fact that you start
blowing your pause times
no we actually do monitor the
memory usage and the gc statistic
statistics of the
the broker so the way we run a lot of
our java applications is they're run
within
a jetty container and the jetty
container is actually instrumented for
us it's one of the nice things that we
get as part of the linkedin deployment
system
uh it's instrumented so it will pick up
all of the metrics from the application
that's running it it will admit
to kafka all of our metrics about how
long our gc intervals are
how much memory is in use um how many
gcs we saw both young and old
it also picks up all of the application
statistics and exports those so some of
the things that we monitor
are both the g the amount of time we're
spending in gc
the amount of heap size that's a heap
that's free within the system
um so we're keeping an eye on that
because if it starts to go up then we're
going to have a problem
uh we actually went through a cycle of
running
update 21 for java 7
which i do not recommend doing it there
were significant improvements to g1
as of i think update 23 or 25
and 51 is even better but we actually
had some significant problems which we
saw manifested in those statistics when
we were running it
you still have to set your size though
yes
we're we're looking for so the big thing
we were looking for with the heap size
and why we went from three gigs to four
gigs is because we were trying to hit
that target so we set the target at 20
milliseconds but with the smaller heap
size we weren't quite hitting it most of
the time
so we we just played with the since we
only had two
toggles to play with at that point that
we were really supposed to be playing
with
we set the heat we set the target time
at 20 milliseconds we thought that was a
good
time based on what we had seen with par
new before that
and so we bumped up the heap size a
little bit
on top of that and so that we saw it
hitting the goal
the nice thing about g1 is that it
handles larger heaps much better
than previous garbage collection because
it breaks it down into smaller
processing pieces
one of the things to point out is it's
really useful to leave the rest of your
memory alone
so that you can use your page cache
because that's where kafka really
starts screaming in terms of performance
yeah so to that point
our brokers are running with 64 gigs of
memory
and the only thing running on a kafka
broker is kafka with a 4 gig heap
everything else on the system is used
for page cache
it's it's used to handle the disk i o in
the network i o make sure things flow
smoothly through the system
oh uh is the new gc uh you're using
oracle
uh jdk or yes do you know if it's an
oracle only feature or
is it i don't believe so i think it's in
open jdk
as far as i know um yeah i
i'm pretty sure it's an open jdk is
essentially a feeder for oracle's jdk
other ways the same way fedora is a
feeder for
red hat features so it's almost
100 i'm almost you know 100 sure that
it's in
it's you'll probably see more stuff
more uh features added in open jdk
before it makes it to the actual oracle
jdk
all right all right so in closing
so 082 is coming out relatively soon um
one of the things that the development
team's doing is they're moving the kafka
offsets
for the consumers to be stored within a
specialized kafka topic
rather than being stored in z keeper we
had lots of issues with zookeeper ssds
you know we're essentially a midterm
solution um
this is the the long-term solution
um so everyone will benefit from it very
soon um
delete topic currently there is no way
to delete a topic
without shutting down the entire
cholesterol at once and removing it
it's a royal pain yeah and we've had to
do this
it's we have but one note there is an
actual delete topic command in 081
don't run it don't run it please do not
run it it was actually
disabled in 0811 because it does not
work
it doesn't actually just not work it
destroys
it has a very high likelihood of
destroying your cluster did you try that
did you learn this the hard way
or the yes yes thankfully in our staging
environment
yeah and it wasn't we didn't run it
another sre at linkedin ran it and
yeah it was a mess um okay so further
down the road
we have a new producer coming out we're
actually starting to test it now
it has higher throughput than an
approved api
it also rather than batching messages
based on
the number of messages in the batch it
batches based on size
which is a whole lot better so you don't
ever exceed your broker maximum message
size
then upcoming operational work so we
failed kindergarten
trying to relearn how to share and you
know that server's not going to come
back online for
a number of days or you know weeks
potentially so what you're able to do is
move all of the partitions that were
assigned to that broker
to other brokers and get the cluster
back in a healthy state while the
that broker's offline we're working on
the script for that right now
um we're also writing a cluster
comparison script so as
todd kind of showed you we mirror our
data everywhere
so one of the big issues we run into
is each topic has its own configuration
in terms of the retention
whether it's size based time based
the number of partitions that it has
there's lots of different attributes for
every single topic
and we might set it on one cluster and
then that data gets married to the next
cluster
well if we don't set it there you know
it never gets set it just takes the
default values and so that's one of one
big problem for us
so we're writing a cluster comparison
tool to make sure that you know for any
given topic
it has the same configuration across all
of our clusters
um then advanced monitoring so
you know one of the big issues we run
into is all of a sudden some producer
will start sending us a ton of data
and we can see you know the data
increase on our graphs
you know the cluster's taking a lot more
data figuring out which topic that is
is pretty difficult so what we're going
to do
is we're going to try and figure out how
to monitor
uh input size over time so compared to
the last hour
the last two hours ago just to see what
the increase will be
um how can you guys get involved you go
to the
kafka webpage you can join the mailing
lists
uh we're on irc um contribute tools
become a committer and then you can talk
to us
here's our contact info we're both on
linkedin imagine that
find us there